c'est une rencontre et peut-être que je
porte en moi depuis l'enfance et j'ai
toujours aimé matière j'ai dit josé
faire des choses avec les mains
l'émotivité nos têtes a fait dit il au
tour en bois et donc alors que j'étais
étudiant un jour je suis découvert le
travail de la noix de coco et j'ai vu
que les gens faisaient des objets qui
étaient en général
estampillée martigny folklore vernis des
formes simples et j'ai eu l'idée
d'approfondir et mon rapport aux
matières naturelles la noix de coco ou à
d'autres matières et au fur et à mesure
jugée pour ainsi dire et développer un
label le label jo bijoux et qui traduit
une posture de quête d'une beauté
particulière avec la matière naturelle
c'est-à-dire toutes sortes de matières
noix de coco calebasse et cas et le
poisson peau de poisson hausse cuir et
j'en passe et c'est un peu comme avec
l'humour
il faut agir c il faut marier les
couleurs les farm les les textiles si je
peux dire et chaque fois produire
quelque chose qui relève peut-être d'un
de dessin mais qui certainement frappe
l'attention par dix ans la qualité du
travail fait avec les matières nature
pas par le travail sur la matière
concernant la conception la création
je suis aussi dans dans une l'élan
politique
j'avoue que je cherche là aussi une
poésie que je trouve dans les mots et
une poésie dans dans la relation à la
nouvelle s de la matière naturelle alors
poésie
dans la noblesse de la matière naturelle
mais poésie aussi à venir est ce que tu
te fais pas ça devrait vous faites les
choses qui ne sont encore dix ans dans
dans une année à venir n'en parle pas
trop mais là je pars bientôt en
guadeloupe ou jouer au mémorial acte
je suis invité dans un festival qui
s'appelle bleu outremer et plus tard en
mars
je vais faire certainement une grande
exposition en guadeloupe dès leurs
bijoux qui donc décoration au corporelle
est aussi objet déco objets d'intérieur
je suis essentiellement branché sur ça
et puis à l'horizon 2019 2020
je pense sortir je vise le cas là bas je
vise le japon je vise l'europe la suisse
la belgique est tous là pour partager
certainement la poésie la latière
naturel mais surtout la scène la poésie
de la scène des textes avec des
musiciens se ce qui est mon activité
préférée mais considérons maintenant que
j'ai deux cordes à mon arc
la corde par le dire poétique et la
corde travail sur la matière et
artisanat d'art si en public